[Music]
hi my name is amir goldberg and i'm a
professor of organizational behavior at
the stanford graduate school of business
where i teach a class titled people
analytics people analytics is the
application of data analytics methods
especially machine learning algorithms
for the purpose of informing
people-related decisions inside
organizations here are five takeaways
from that class
[Music]
data are revolutionizing how people are
managing inside organizations using data
analytics doesn't mean that you need to
be a data analyst
what you need to be is someone who
understands what data analytics can and
cannot do and most importantly
understand how to interpret data
analytics in terms of what it means
about what's happening inside your
organization
it's really important for you to
understand what algorithms can or cannot
do
and people call it artificial
intelligence but machines are not
intelligent in the way that humans are
what are they good at prediction by
which i mean looking at historical data
and then making predictions about the
future
your role is to use those predictions as
a means to inform your decisions
it is you who makes the decisions
it's the machines who make the
predictions
[Music]
there's a lot of snake oil out there
if it sounds fantastical it's probably
no good
it's very difficult to predict human
behavior the most important thing for
you to ask is
is this prediction predicting an outcome
that i actually care about
if the person who developed the
algorithm can demonstrate to you that it
moves the needle on outcomes that are
important for you then it's worth
considering
but if they can't
you should probably take a pass
[Music]
when it comes to making decisions about
other humans
all of us are biased we pay attention to
other people's race to their gender to
their physical appearance to their
accent and those are often entirely
irrelevant to the decisions that we need
to make
so use your algorithms in a way that
would help you
overcome those biases and make your
decisions
better and more ethical
when it comes to making decisions about
other people those can be immensely
consequential they can relate to their
livelihood to their sense of worth to
their psychological well-being we can't
take those lightly and it's really
important that when you make these
decisions you don't hide behind machines
nor do you outsource the morality of the
decision to a machine learning decision
maker ultimately it's your
responsibility machines are neither
moral or immoral they do what you tell
them to and it's important that you
think about the moral implications of
your decisions the good news
ethical decisions are also better
managerial decisions good luck
[Music]
my mom once said in a class and at the
end of the class he said to me uh amir i
have no idea what you said but you're a
genius
whereas my dad said
that was very interesting but you didn't
teach them anything did you uh
so that gives you a good kind of summary
of how my parents took the class
[Music]
you